hey youtubers is Charlie and earlier
this week in my arrow review I asked you
to all submit your questions about the
epic mess that Slade is making for Team
arrow I picked 10 of them with one bonus
question to answer in this video I tried
to stick to the really important stuff
you know like new characters team ups
and flash related stuff if you're
finding me for the first time I
typically do Q&A videos for Big Show's
just so we can talk a little bit more
about the most interesting parts be sure
to subscribe to get everything and let's
answer some questions so number one
comes from count swag EULA may be
episode 20 seeing red could be Roy's
first appearance as red arrow or Barry
Allen coming back or Roy putting on the
tights so that's a good question we
actually know a couple things
Roy will get his suit and characters
from the flash are coming to arrow or
back to arrow before the end of the
season so like a lot of episode titles I
think that it means both things there is
a special announcement that goes
hand-in-hand with episode 20 it has a
lot to do with episode 19 and the
potential for a supporting character to
die a lot of the questions and my
answers subsequently tie back into this
so I'll be elaborating across the rest
of this Q&A though question number two
Tom Steven asks I thought that it would
be 20 episodes in season 2 you're saying
instead of 23 there are currently 23
listed on the futon critic so what's
happening is there's a break next week
then on March 19th
there's episode 15 the Suicide Squad and
every week after that will be a new
episode until the finale that episode 23
will be on May 14th we only know the
titles of the episodes up to 18 and
episode 20 in order those are Suicide
Squad birds-of-prey
Deathstroke and seeing red we don't know
the names of episodes 19 or the last
four yet question number three red arrow
1596 asks do you think Amanda Waller
will approach Slade in the season finale
and ask him to join the Suicide Squad
and what do you think about their
potential for becoming sort of the alt
together big bad for season 3 so if
you're asking if Slade is going to join
the Suicide Squad or if the Suicide
Squad is going to be the big bad for
season 3 it's kind of a no for both of
those questions I'll say probably not
for that first part and definitely not
to the second
the Suicide Squad are great anti-heroes
those are like protagonists that aren't
necessarily good guys like evil people
working with good guys towards a common
goal under a temporary ceasefire it's
possible that the members of the Suicide
Squad could go rogue in the future but
then Amanda Waller would just send the
rest of the squad to kill or capture
them I'll talk more about potential big
bads for season 3 when we get closer to
the finale there's still so many things
we don't know about how the seasons
going to end question number four Sarah
sunshine asks do you think that it's
possible to see Slade's children
sometime later like Rose or Jericho so
thank you for asking this question
because I was just thinking of like a
Darth Vader arc for Slade what I mean is
that Darth Vader starts out as a good
person Anakin Skywalker and when you
watch Star Wars movies starting with
episode one ending with Return of the
Jedi the overarching story becomes the
redemption of Vader so all Star Wars
isn't really Luke's story it's really
the story of Vader's fall from grace and
ultimate redemption what happened to
cause Vader to seek Redemption his
children showed up in the comics slays
children pretty much hate him for being
so evil but we really don't know how
arrow is going to deal with that
relationship Slade was lying when he
said they didn't have any children
during the last episode though Oliver
specifically mentioned Jericho on the
island in episode 12 it was when Slade
first started to freak out on the
mirakuru in the comics he had another
son grant the first Ravager who died and
a daughter Rose who became the second
Ravager after her brother's death
they're kind of like a back door to a
Teen Titans show with Roy Harper I'm
kind of crossing my fingers that air is
going to go this Darth Vader route with
Slade's character the exception being
that he's not going to die at the end
question number 5 ice white scarab asks
because there was a girl with blond hair
and black fingernails do you think that
Harley Quinn will be introduced in the
Suicide Squad episode you're talking
about this girl
so I definitely think that it's Harley
Quinn there are a couple of the theories
but based on the nail polish and the
link to the comic books it makes a lot
of sense given the big moments arrow has
already given us with the other a-list
supers like the flash this season
there's an even bigger character coming
in the finale which all speechify in
just a little bit though question number
6 Michael Hernandes asks could the blond
girl in the jail
help this girl beat Tara instead of
Harlequin Tara does have a partnership
with Deathstroke in the comics so it's
definitely another possibility remember
in episode 12 tremors the earthquake
machine was being bought by someone in
markovia
that would have been Tara's father in
the comics she started working with
Deathstroke and ultimately infiltrated
the Teen Titans so hey I guess if it
does turn out that crazy hair girl is
Tara it's just more evidence that CW is
trying to develop a Teen Titans show so
everybody get excited about that
question number 7 JK FGM asks do you
think that it's a possibility that
Felicity might be AI Beau's daughter so
this is actually a really good theory
that a lot of people have been talking
about the backstory Felicity has given
us lines up with a lot of what we know
about Ivo on the show and it would be
one more way to make her part of Slade
completing his you know awesome full
circle revenge that started with shadows
death I definitely think that it would
really add a nice dimension to
Felicity's character the big question
though is what happened to Ivo after
Slade chopped his hand off he didn't die
in the episode kind of cut off in the
middle of that story question number 8
Shabaab should be her asks do you think
that Malcolm Merlyn will appear in this
villain arc so he has to come back at
some point there are a couple of
theories he could be working on his own
to win over Thea he does care about
family he totally went nuts when Tommy
died and the only reason he came back to
Starling was for Thea
the other possibility is that he's
working with Slade and just using the
opportunity to win Thea over remember he
doesn't want to hurt her I don't think
this is a good theory though and we know
he's keeping his distance from the
League of Assassins
but during heir to the demon Sarah did
name-drop him when Merlyn does come back
and he definitely will expect that the
league won't be too far behind him
either to stop him or to help him his
character is really closely linked with
them this season so they're not gonna be
far behind him question number 9
Ella nappa Dadich asks when flash starts
will it work with arrows storyline or
will it have its own so it's easier to
follow for people who don't watch arrow
so yes you will be able to watch the
flash without watching arrow but I don't
recommend it you'd be missing so many
Easter eggs and references characters
from both shows are going to be jumping
back and forth so I would say definitely
watch air
oh it's so good I'm guessing the reason
you're asking is because you or someone
you know is a huge Grant Gustin fan but
not a fan of the people on arrow that is
totally okay but you should definitely
tell your friends to start watching
arrow tell them to drink the kool-aid
question number 10 bank made asks that
just a crazy name do you think that
there would be a series of events
leading up to Sarah dying and Laurel
being injected with mirakuru and thus
becoming the new Black Canary so Marc
Guggenheim said there's a really special
announcement around episode 19 he used
this with an Aaron Sorkin quote about an
episode of The West Wing where one of
the big characters died we don't know
what the announcement he's going to make
is but based on that West Wing reference
it sounds a lot like someone from Team
arrow is going to die right now the
biggest possibilities from least to most
likely are Laurel Thea and then Sara
so yes right now sara is the highest on
my hit list it would fit thematically
with Slade completing his circle of
revenge making Oliver choose whether he
kills Sarah or Felicity just the same
way shado died another possibility is
that Thea dies and Merlyn calls down the
League of Assassins on Slade but that's
not really as likely because remember
Oliver's quote Ra's al Ghul would be
trouble for everyone heroes and villains
by the way Manu Bennett definitely did
drop that Ra's al Ghul was coming to
Starling city Marc Guggenheim kind of
did the same thing teasing a major
surprise like this in the finale
he didn't say Ra's al Ghul but he did
say that it was something that would
depend on a bunch of other stuff working
out behind the scenes so it could still
fall through so yes he is still coming
but it's not official until the arrow
people make it official they are doing
everything they can to use the character
on the show though no idea on who would
play him or if liam neeson would just
reprise the role he probably would not
though and one last bonus question Vijay
Krishna Nasus who do you think that
person was who knocked out Diggle that
was actually the Huntress if you look
closely she's got belt buckles here and
the stick weapons that look just like
the ones in the clips from the
birds-of-prey episode so thank you so
much guys for submitting your questions
this was a lot of fun as always and
thank you so much for your patience and
me getting my videos out I had a ton of
extra real life work this week it makes
it
so much harder to get videos at on time
so tonight I'm going to try and catch up
on Hannibal and community videos but
there's also a bunch of other stuff that
I'm still trying to do I still owe you
guys South Park stick of truth' new
Doctor Who game of Thrones and anime
club all before Monday I'm gonna try and
spread it all out so hopefully I will
have time to get it all done if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get that stuff it's a lot
of fun to make hopefully it will be my
full-time job to just make videos
someday until then click here to watch
that epic arrow trailer again and click
here to watch my review the episode
thank you so much I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives